alright so it's been about a week now
give or take dark below has come out yep
I'll get your impressions I know you
haven't done the raid yet but like
you're about to yes I you know leading
up to now having dealt with zur dealt
with the vendors of the new tier and
whatnot and the story missions of course
a big deal the right story this time and
what are your general impressions of you
know what you kind of gone through good
and bad i guess so i think the dark
below basically confirm what my fears
for this game and bungie would be from
that from the beginning and that was
that they wouldn't really know where to
focus their efforts and what i mean by
that is like you have obviously casual
players and you have hardcore players
and the problem with trying to appeal to
both is that you're going to end up
pissing both of them off I feel like
with the dart below hardcore players
took a massive hit with you know the
exotics resetting like the iron banner
armor being basically made worthless the
second the dark below came out not only
was that iron banner year useless if you
had rated it's kind of the same thing
right like you're dealing with gear that
will get you to light level 30 obviously
and I know with every kind of expansion
in like like an MMO even though this is
not an MMO you're always going to be
changing gear right I just found it
weird that I guess maybe because the
time it's only been three months but the
fact that somebody can come in and just
get gear that's better than the gear
just rated for like home with like day
one it's kind of disappointing to me a
little bit it's kind of sad that I guess
like you said we're hardcore players
because I play a lot that a lot of the
time I spent investing into the game I
didn't really see that much benefit
going forward by generally in like a
game like wow you'd like the set items
and whatnot they are lower level but
they set item is so strong or whatever
that you can still use it all the way up
until you're done leveling or whatever
it's not the case in this game
and also by having new materials of like
radiant energy and radiant shards it
kind of made I wouldn't say ascendant
shards and ascendant energies are
useless it's just me stockpiling over
100 is kind of whatever now you know one
of my biggest problems with what they've
done if you're giving hardcore players
the shaft casual players can come in
they can hit 20 and almost instantly hit
31 or they can get get there really
quickly because the vendors sell all
that gear now and they've made it super
simple in the process they made vault of
glass completely worthless and for me I
thought the point of destiny was the
raid or are the raids you know you're
getting all this gear you're getting all
these weapons you're grinding rep you're
doing all this stuff for the purpose of
being able to participate in the raid
and not only have they made one major
aspect of the game completely useless I
mean vault of glass is still a huge
chunk of that game and for hardcore
players now it's it's it's almost a
complete waste of time I mean you can
still get shards and stuff that you need
to upgrade weapons and all that stuff
but you know the hard mode stuff the
hard mode weapons are you know like fake
bringer is which I use a lot that in
maybe middle class you know there's like
those few kind of things like if you
don't have it yet I guess it would be
good to have it but it's not a game
changer outside of like 90 Allie's
current but so like you you would expect
that Bungie would walk it's casual
audience to play ball to glass because
it's like here look at what look at the
best stuff that we have you know their
friends are who play destiny may be a
little bit more than a door ding dong
don't bother so it's like you in the
process of trying to make it so casual
players can quickly get to 31 they've
basically just you know cut off a huge
piece of content and in a game where
content is already a little bit light
like that seems a huge huge mistake to
me you know I don't necessarily have a
problem with the exotic resets either if
anything it kind of makes me realize
that I don't use most of them anyway but
that's also bad to you because that
shows that so much of their exotic
weaponry the fact that it's maybe not
all that useful maybe they should make
them useful and they have to communicate
right now that for the future expansion
that this stuff won't happen again like
if there's not going to be another reset
there's not going to be
you know just your armor that you get in
the hard mode rate or in just the right
in general for kotas n it's not going to
be made useless the second house of
wolves comes out yeah I mean definitely
communication has been kind of a big
thing and the lack thereof I think they
know that now the community has been
very vocal about it just not knowing
exactly what we had to do for resets and
stuff like that not even knowing even
myself that it was in a cost you know
upwards a 7,000 glimmer her exotic
upgrade and I did three of those and
that's you know that's the bank and that
stuff they need to tell people ahead of
time so if you are more casual and you
know spend that much time playing the
game you're not farming glimmer all the
time you don't have enough money to
upgrade 40 right and there comes once a
week and you may miss out on that
upgrade because you weren't prepared but
I mean like granted we're talking kind
of negatively i think there's still like
some good things yes the story missions
there definitely a lot better they're
cooked more cohesive the story is better
it's not great but it's better the new
strike is hard yeah how are you
surprisingly hard i mean what i would i
like about this strike especially when
it was on the night fall for the first
week is that it still seemed doable like
I felt like as long as I have a team of
people we won't need to cheese it you
know even if somebody did find a
cheesing spa I felt like it's not
necessary you can you know take this
thing down it's going to take a little
while but I don't feel like it's an
impossible task and I and I agree I like
what they've done with the new story
stuff and I agree that the era stuff is
a nice addition it doesn't go far enough
one of the reasons why I keep playing
and one of the things that the dark
below does really well is that the
universe that they've established is
great and I think they've done a very
good job of establishing a foundation
the problem is they're not going they're
not building off of it in a way that's
very satisfying and I would like to see
them take the time to start explaining
more stuff I don't want to spoil too
much but I'll speak about the raid I
think they're doing great job with just
rate like the general rate environment
it looks amazing it plays very fun until
people find cheeses I guess that well
not will not reach hard mode now I think
maybe a good thing they held off on that
but aside from the cheese like the first
time going in there
again just a lot of those Wow almost
like holy [ __ ] moment so this is really
cool like the environments really cool
we spent an hour on the second part the
first night not knowing like what are we
supposed to do like there's this bridge
that's kind of forming there's these
swords like what are we supposed to do
that's the fun element of it the only
problem i guess i have is sadly once i
finish this and then i get it on farm
i'm probably gonna play like once or
twice a week again and that's about it
and like you said that's kind of the
lack of content in the game destiny is a
fantastic looking game like the art
direction it's just so well done if
nothing else because i see how well they
execute on things like that it makes me
want to see more you know like I I feel
like they're on the right track but
they're just repeating mistakes that
some mmos have made in the past like I
don't understand things like you know
iron banner is the next iron banner is
already coming up it's like why not wait
a little bit let people experience the
rave to get you know what I mean it's
it's something you almost want to save
like right before hard mode when when
your contents kind of slowly drying up
you want to get that little kick start
that little revitalization of like
playerbase I'm just building upon that
you know if power is everything as iron
banner is supposed to be and you know
the armor difference and one else was
and make that difference into faerie
person to your opponent's the fact that
you've only had a week of time to play
dark glow you're not going to be
everyone's kind of gonna be the same in
my opinion I don't think there's gonna
be too much disparity and iron banner
was supposed to make it feel like there
was disparity right like you could tell
when you're fighting a 26 when you're 30
like yeah you're not going to hurt me as
much as I'm going to hurt you and even
if I have that in your probably gonna
lose but right now I feel like there's
gonna be a lot of 30 months yeah I mean
I will say it dark glow like the rest of
destiny pretty much is like there's a
lot of really interesting things that
they're doing there's a lot of cool
places they could go but I feel like
there's
enough of it and that they're still
trying to strike a weird balance between
casual players and hardcore players and
I know that's a necessary sort of evil
but you have at the very least and
they've acknowledged this you have to
respect people's time so when you do
stuff like the weaponry sets so quickly
after people just built them up it's not
that's not a good way just work
acknowledged that yeah I mean it's going
to be that struggle for Bundy to figure
out kind of the sweet spot for them to
you know here's the kind of wine for the
casuals to help them out but then
there's enough for the hardcore to want
to do it too and I don't know what that
line is like wow figured it out it took
them a while though you know and the
only time will tell if destiny figures
it out before destiny